this video let's look at the periodic
trends for ionization energy so for this
period as we go across from lithium all
the way over to neon so as we go this
way across our periodic table we can see
in general there's an increase in the
ionization energy so lithium is positive
520 kilojoules per mole
beryllium goes up to 900 kilojoules per
mole and then again and general we see
this increase in ionization energies
going over to neon so going across a
period is an increase in the ionization
energy that's because as we go across
our period there's an increase in the
effective nuclear charge so increase in
the effective and remember the formula
for that is the effective nuclear charge
is equal to on the actual number of
protons which is Z and from that we
subtract S which is the average number
of inner electrons shielding our outer
electrons so let's examine this in more
detail looking at lithium and beryllium
lithium has atomic number 3 so 3 protons
in the nucleus so positive 3 charge and
lithium's electron configuration we know
is 1s2 2s1 so two electrons in our 1s
orbital and one electron in the 2's
orbital beryllium has one more proton
and one more electron so one more proton
in the nucleus so a +4 charge and for
beryllium the electron configuration is
1s2 2s2 so two electrons in the 1s
orbital and then two electrons in the
2's orbital let's calculate the
effective nuclear charge for both of
these and first we'll start with lithium
so for lithium lithium has a +3 charge
in the nucleus so the effective nuclear
charge is equal to positive 3 and from
that we subtract the average number of
inner electrons shielding or outer
electrons in this case we have these 2
and
or core electrons that are shielding our
outer electron our valence electron from
this full positive three charge so we
know that like charges repel so this
electron is going to repel this electron
a little bit and this electron repelled
this electron and these two inner core
electrons of lithium have a shielding
effect they protect the outer electron
from the full positive three charge so
there's two shielding electrons so for a
quick effective nuclear charge
calculation positive three minus two
gives us a value of +1 for the effective
nuclear charge so it's like this outer
electron of lithium is feeling a nuclear
charge of +1 which pulls it toward the
nucleus right so there's an attractive
force between the outer electron and and
our nucleus now the actual calculation
for this on z2 s I should say does not
have to be an integer the actual value
for lithium is approximately 1.3 but our
quick crude calculation tells us
positive 1 let's do the same calculation
for beryllium so the effective nuclear
charge for beryllium is equal to the
number of protons right which for
beryllium is positive 4 from that we
subtract the number of inner electrons
that are shielding the outer electrons
so it's a similar situation we have two
inner electrons that are shielding this
outer electron right they're repelling
this outer electron shielding the outer
electron from the full positive 4 charge
of the nucleus so we say there are two
inner electrons so the effective nuclear
charge is positive 4 minus 2 giving up
giving us an effective nuclear charge of
positive 2 in reality the effective
nuclear charge is approximately 1.9 and
that's because beryllium has another
electron in a 2 s orbital over here
which does affect this electron a little
bit repels it a little bit and so it
actually decreases the effective nuclear
charge to about 1.9 but again for a
quick calculation positive to work
so the outer electron for beryllium
let's just choose this one again it's
feeling an effective nuclear charge of
positive 2 which means that it's going
to be pulled closer to the nucleus
there's a greater attractive force on
this outer electron for beryllium as
compared to this outer electron for
lithium the effective nuclear charge is
only plus 1 for this outer electron and
because of this the beryllium atom is
smaller right the 2's orbital gets
smaller and the atom itself is smaller
beryllium is smaller than lithium so
this outer electron here let me switch
colors again this outer electron for
beryllium is closer to the nucleus than
the outer electron for lithium feels a
greater attractive force and therefore
it takes more energy to pull this
electron away from the neutral beryllium
atom and that's the reason for the
higher ionization energy so beryllium
has an ionization energy a positive 900
kilojoules per mole compared to
lithium's of 520 kilojoules per mole so
it has to do with the effective nuclear
charge
so far we've compared lithium and
beryllium we saw to the ionization what
energy went from positive 520 kilojoules
roll to 900 kilojoules per mole and we
said that was because of the increased
effective nuclear charge for beryllium
but as you go from beryllium to boron
there's still an increased effective
nuclear charge but notice our ionization
energy goes from 900 kilojoules per mole
for beryllium to only 800 kilojoules per
mole for boron there's a slight decrease
in the ionization energy and let's look
at the electron configuration of boron
see if we can explain that boron has 5
electrons so the electron configuration
is 1s2 2s2 and 2p 1 so that fifth
electron of boron goes into a 2p orbital
and the 2p orbital is higher in energy
than a 2's orbital which means the
electron the 2p orbital is on average
further away from the nucleus and the
two electrons in the
u.s. orbital so we just get this out
really quickly let's say that's my 2's
orbital I have two electrons in there
and this 1 electron in the 2p orbital is
on average further away from the nucleus
so those two electrons in the 2's
orbital actually can repel this electron
in the 2p orbital so there's a little
bit extra shielding there of the 2p
electron from the full attraction of the
nucleus right so even though we have 5
protons a nucleus and a positive 5
charge for boron the fact that these 2's
electrons add a little bit of extra
shielding means it's easier to pull this
electron away so it turns out to be a
little bit easier to pull this electron
the 2p orbital away due to these 2's
electrons and that's the reason for this
slight decrease in ionization energy as
we go from boron to carbon we see an
increase in ionization energy from
carbon to nitrogen and increase in
ionization energy again we attribute
that to increased effective nuclear
charge but when we go from nitrogen to
oxygen we see a slight decrease again
from about 1,400 kilojoules per mole
down to about 1300 kilojoules per mole
for oxygen so let's see if we can
explain that by writing out some
electron configurations for nitrogen and
oxygen nitrogen has 7 electrons to think
about so its electron configuration is
1s2 2s2 and 2p threes that takes care of
all seven electrons for oxygen we have
another electron so 1s2 2s2 2p4 is the
electron configuration for oxygen let's
just draw using orbital notation the 2's
orbital and the 2p orbitals so for
nitrogen here's our 2's orbital we have
two electrons in there so let's draw in
our two electrons and for our 2p
orbitals we have 3 electrons so here are
the 2p orbitals and let's draw in our 3
electrons using orbital note
let's do the same thing for oxygen so
there's a 2 s orbital for oxygen which
is full so we'll sketch in those two
electrons we have 4 electrons in the 2p
orbitals which are on the 2p orbitals
there's one electron there's 2 there's 3
and notice what happens when we add the
fourth electron we're adding it to an
orbital that already has an electron in
it so when I add that fourth electron to
the 2p orbital its repelled by the
electron that's already there which
means it's easier to remove one of those
electrons so electrons have like charges
and like charges repel and so that's the
reason for this slight decrease in
ionization energy so it turns out to be
a little bit easier to remove an
electron from an oxygen atom than
nitrogen due to this repulsion in this
2p orbital from there on we see our our
general trend again the ionization
energy for fluorine is up to 16 81 and
then again for neon we see an increase
in the ionization energy due to the
increased effective nuclear charge